quand je suis arrivé on endort il ya un
an je connaissais deux mots en catalan
souk créative c'est le nom de la société
que j'ai créée en andorre pour
redémarrer les activités
depuis un mois je parle et j'apprends le
catalan donc je sais dire m diq jean
marc et des choses comme ça mais il vaut
mieux que je continue en france est pour
vous je vais commencer avec cette phrase
d'un d'un psychologue célèbre qui qui
nous montrent plusieurs caractéristiques
de la créativité
la première c'est que ce n'est pas
quelque chose pour les experts c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut appliquer dans
la vie de tous les jours ce n'est pas
une compétence
c'est une attitude et quand on fait un
potage ou nas ou pas on peut appliquer
la créativité on peut parce que manquant
légumes parce qu'on manque quelque chose
appliquez la créativité pour faire
quelque chose qui est bon qui est
créatif seulement dans dans notre vie
dans notre éducation dans les médias
dans tout ce que qui nous tombe sur nous
comme information nous sommes limités on
limite notre créativité
on nous fait penser tous de la même
façon et c'est un point important de la
créativité c'est de pouvoir sortir du
cadre dans lequel on est ça c'est un
verset de la bible que j'aime beaucoup
et on peut encore aujourd'hui apprendre
beaucoup de la sagesse de salomon et ce
verset nous dit plusieurs choses mais la
première c'est que
la nature peut être une source
d'inspiration et ça s'appelle le
biomimétisme s'étend à des outils
principal de la créativité c'est aller
chercher dans la nature des inspirations
et si on regarde les fourmis
si on regarde ce qu'elles font on peut
comprendre en regardant leurs voix le
chemin qu'elle pratique que
l'exploration est quelque chose qu elle
pratique en permanence et qui nous aide
à être créatifs l'exploration nous aide
à être créatif et nous aident à devenir
sage c'est à dire à devenir plus
intelligent et je vais passer un exemple
est ce que quelqu'un dans la salle ces
succès n'ont personne personne n'ose
c'est en turquie
c'est un caravansérail
et comme en andorre le commerce à
l'époque en 1300 avait des problèmes et
il y a eu des améliorations pour
améliorer le commerce était la seule
route de la soie la route du café la
route de l'inde
il est les caravanes de marchands
avaient des problèmes de sécurité
on a fait des améliorations on a
amélioré on a fait des caves
caravansérail
c'est une innovation d'amélioration est
ce que quelqu'un sait ce que c'est oui
j'entends des gens qui disent que c'est
donc voilà c'est là les caravelles de
christophe colomb qui est qui et le
premier la première start-up qu'on
connaît il a il avait une idée en dehors
de la pensée unique de l'époque qui
disaient que la terre était plate
il avait un financier la reine isabelle
et il est parti il est parti quoi faire
il est parti en inde et n'est jamais
arrivé mais il a découvert autre chose
et donc on apprend que avec
l'exploration avec le fait de dépasser
le savoir de l'époque de pouvoir aller
au delà il a découvert quelque chose de
merveilleux il avait découvert
l'amérique et il a fait vraiment une
très très bonne start up
ça c'est le slide le plus difficile à
comprendre et ça nous parle de de
l'éveil et de la résilience
alors la résilience c'est quoi c'est la
capacité personnelle de passer au dessus
d'un proc d'un gros problème et on ici
on voit que à gauche c'est une image de
du d'un film qui amusant wali dans
lequel on voit des gens qui sont qui
sont dans un univers complètement
prédictif qui sont dans le confort qui
n'ont plus rien à penser on pourrait
dire que le cerveau bas comme un reptile
pour l'est pourrait leur suffire
ils sont dans un mode où ils ne sont pas
éveillé par contre si on arrive avec des
solutions créatives si on accepte d'être
différent d'avoir des choses nouvelles
devant nos yeux on va éveiller notre
cerveau donc d'un côté on peut
s'endormir on peut être complètement
passif de l'autre côté on s'éveille et
on peut devenir de plus en plus créatifs
ce qui arriva
à la conclusion que je voulais faire
aujourd'hui c'est que la créativité et
votre créativité est quelque chose que
vous pouvez cultiver et qui va vous
aider à grandir et donc dans un monde
qui change tout au dessus on peut devoir
s'adapter on peut devoir utiliser la
créativité votre créativité pour trouver
des solutions de rupture le fait qu'on
trouve des solutions de rupture va vous
ouvrir votre esprit va vous faire
grandir pas vous faire vous éveillez et
une fois que vous êtes éveillé que votre
esprit grandi vous pouvez de nouveau
comprendre mieux les problèmes qui
suivent donc chaque fois que vous faites
ce cercle d'un cercle vertueux la
créativité vous aide dans le futur à de
nouveaux grandir plus vite merci